hey this is really exciting I just ran
into these guys and tell me what your
job used to be we used to translate your
code and the Magnetic put on the Brian
did it translate well in the Hebrew who
did my sense of humor translate that was
so instantaneous that's right yes I nice
to see it in the 90s I played in NBA
star from the 90s Johnson for you a
minute for that correction you know for
me yeah you made a dreidel for me and
you made it out of clay yeah and when it
was no dreidel dreidel dreidel I don't
know it's like you don't know an
American I thought that was a Jewish
song vandal dreidel dreidel I'm feeling
really sad fatal fatal fatal
my childhood was no bad hey check this
out tomorrow here sir have a seat
good to see you I just noticed this
other guy drinking alone you were just
sitting there alone having a drink
yeah and I thought I'm drinking alone
you're drinking alone let's drink alone
together yeah what's your name
Jacob let me ask you something what do
you do you're a lifeguard you want like
the most confident guy look at the way
you're sitting
I should simply you look at that guy and
you're bleeding back off your lifeguard
look at you you don't worry about stuff
do you you don't worry about getting
older you know your cholesterol level
you don't worry about that stuff this
move that we denied give me a paper take
them
show me your lifeguard stands in a tall
chair now let me guess you're like what
what suppose that what do you do what
did you do that for your nose you rub
your own testicle that's ridiculous
and what if a girl looks at you show me
your look to the girl that's your look
right there don't you do that what was
this what was that okay
it seems clear that you've never swam in
your life drinking alone
[Applause]
you